[Music]
or bolt-action rifles to shotguns
there's something in battlefield one to
fit all play styles but what about those
level 10 weapons for each class on
average it will take you a few weeks
grinding in a single class to unlock
just one of these rare weapons so how do
you know if any of them are worth
grinding for don't worry we're here to
help you decide which level 10 weapon is
right for you
the martini-henry with max out damage
and accuracy at first glance this rifle
appears to be a one-hit killing machine
this gun hits for high damage on the
body but my problem with it is the long
reload animation I know this may sound
funny but picture this when using a
rater of bolt-action rifle the bolt
cycle animation between shots takes less
than a second the Henry is breech
loading 1 slow round at a time that few
seconds leaves you wide open and close
to medium range if you don't kill your
target with the first shot also for
those of you who love using scoped
rifles sorry this rifle is an iron sight
only it's a cool gun and packs the power
but I really found myself returning to
some of my old bolt-action rifles such
as the smle MK 3 infantry for better
reliability but has a nice side bonus
once you reach a level 10 as the Scout
you unlock the baby pistol isn't it cute
the problem is you really can't kill
with it
next up is the sub slaughter 1906
factory rifle for the medic class if you
ever used an m1 grand and pass
battlefield games you'll feel right at
home with this gun with good damage and
high accuracy this weapon became my
favorite accessory to a med pack the
downside to this weapon just like the m1
grand is that it only has 5 rounds per
clip three shots to the chest will kill
your foe and the remaining rounds can be
used to kill an enemy at half health
this rifle isn't the best in outnumbered
moments like the other medic rifles such
as the m-19 o 7 SL sweeper by the
autoloading 8.25 extended but this gun
is well worth the grinding if being a
medic is your style the level chugging
gun you most likely will see on the
field is the hell réguel 1915 factory
SMG for the assault class packing a
monstrous rate of fire and control this
SMG is one of the best guns you can grab
for your assault however that doesn't
mean this weapon doesn't have its faults
for starters it packs a 60 round
magazine but you only have 60 rounds
left in reserve so unless you're near a
support handing out ammunition you're
going to be running out of ammo fast
also to note that despite the rate of
fire it packs low damage and decent
accuracy so is this gun really worth it
for the assault class absolutely
if you willing to deal with the
ammunition drawbacks
last but not least is the hold automatic
lightweight LMG for the support class on
paper this thing is a beast with
best-in-class accuracy but as anyone who
plays Battlefield knows you don't judge
a gun by its stats the hold also sports
hefty spread or even with the bipod
deployed an earlier unlock the bar is
better at putting up high damage rounds
on a target at close range and the Lewis
gun with high ammo capacity relatively
fast reloads performs better at range
the low ammo count for this weapon also
hurts the LMG class where weapons become
more accurate the longer they are fired
if you love handing out boxes of ammo by
all means play the support but if you're
grinding to level 10 this gun just
doesn't live up to the stats and there
you have it folks for rare level 10 guns
to sink your teeth into at the end of
the day go after the gun that best fits
your play style and I'll see you on the
battlefield for more on your favorite
games keep it here on GameSpot